[Music]
not just a few MCU fans shed tears when
Iron Man sacrificed his life in the
final battle against Thanos in order to
save everyone else it has been known for
a while that there will be a successor
in the suit and now it has finally been
announced ironheart will be the next
superhero in the super suit and she made
her first appearance in the recently
released MCU movie Black Panther wakanda
forever but who exactly is ironheart
whose real name is Riri Williams what
will the new MCU Series be about and who
will be your adversary we asked
ourselves these questions and decided to
answer them for you in this video in
addition another superhero lineup is
nearly complete with the series but more
on that later for now let's get into the
video
before we dive into the cast let's first
take a look at what's happened so far
there might be spoilers to wakanda
Forever here so if you haven't seen the
movie yet and don't want to get spoiled
you better skip this video alright after
all the disclaimers let's get started as
we know MIT student Ruby Williams was
brought to wakanda after developing a
device that can detect vibranium this
was misused by the FBI and so the fight
against Neymar began Williams received
her suit in wakanda and helped in the
fight against the telecon kingdom leader
however she had to leave the suit in
wakanda though this did not stop the
smart inventor from developing a new
suit to take up the fight against other
villains at MIT she certainly has all
kinds of possibilities to play around
with or maybe she'll get her suit back
from wakanda after all thus the series
will take place after the events of
wakanda forever how far after that is
not yet clear but since the series were
released on Disney plus next year it can
be assumed that it will take place at
most a few months within the MCU this
makes it one of the most recent Series
in movies in the MCU in terms of
timeline since the series will also be
set in the middle of phase five this
only makes sense so far no release date
has been announced except for the
information that will be released in the
fall of 2023
even though there are already all kinds
of names in the cast of ironheart most
of the roles are unfortunately still
undisclosed even though filming has
already been completed therefore we can
spend some time to go into more detail
about the antagonists alongside Riri
the lead role is of course played by
Dominique Thorne in her role as Riri
Williams for the 24 year old black
panther wakanda forever was the first
major film in her young career as
ironheart however she was already
impressive there and so we were even
more looking forward to seeing her again
in the series of the same name as we
know young Riri is exceptionally
intelligent which earned her a
scholarship at MIT unlike in the comics
she is not recruited by Tony Stark
indeed there she follows in his
footsteps after he falls into a coma
during Civil War in a fight with Captain
Marvel in the MCU however shurina Okoye
intervene after Namor once her dead as a
result she is first taken to wakanda
there she has the technical skills to
construct the ironheart suit she created
herself unlike Iron Man she has two
thrusters on her back for flying and a
blaster on each hand since she doesn't
have shrapnel in her bloodstream like
Tony Stark which threatened to enter her
heart she can also do without the mini
Arc Reactor in her chest
the antagonist is also already known and
it will be a new one in the MCU his name
is Parker Robbins better known as the
hood in the series he'll be played by 31
year old actor Anthony Ramos who was
last seen in the musical film in the
Heights Robins grew up around crime at
an early age as his father worked for
the Kingpin therefore he followed in his
Father's Footsteps and also came an
ordinary Petty criminal until he killed
a demon of dormammu this demon had a
magical cloak and boots on him which
Robins also immediately grabbed the
cloak could make him invisible as long
as he can hold his breath plus from then
on he can transform into a demon and is
able to fire energy blast from his hands
in the comics he attacks doctor strange
but is then stopped by The Avengers he
also joins various super villains such
as the dark Illuminati this will
certainly be different in ironheart
especially since there's no information
yet that there'll be a crossover with
Doctor Strange of course we are still
very curious to see how the comic book
character will be implemented in the MCU
however he does not have to remain alone
as there are rumors about another super
villain from the Iron Man Universe
Ezekiel Zeke stain the son of
obadiastine who was killed by Tony at
the end of the movie in Iron Man 1 is
also said to play a key role in the new
series rumors also suggest that he'll be
portrayed by Han Solo actor Alden
ehrenreich after the death of his father
Zeke remains in hiding and is also
considered a genius developer he buys
Stark technology on the black market and
uses it defies cybernetic enhancements
that he implants in himself he also
built himself a suit to protect his
implants of course in the comics he
seeks direct combat with Iron Man since
he killed his father but it does fit
very well into the story that he might
want to take revenge on his father by
targeting the person who followed in
Iron Man's footsteps it remains to be
seen whether this will really happen but
we really like the idea
furthermore Jim Rash Harper Anthony
lyric Ross Manny Montana Shay koulet Zoe
Therese Reagan Aaliyah Shakira Barrera
Rashida olayawola Paul Calderon and
Chris summer have already been cast in
the series however in keeping with
Disney nothing is known about their
roles yet and we will have to wait to
learn more about them
ironheart is one of the youngest
superheroes in the Marvel Universe and
was only created in 2016 by Brian
Michael Bendis and cartoonist Mike
deodato as early as 2020 Kevin feige
announced that the comic would get its
own series on the in-house streaming
service Disney plus as a scriptwriter
shanaka hodge was signed on sitting in
the director's chair are Sam Bailey and
Angela Barnes filming did not begin
until June 2nd 2022 however they already
wrapped up filming five months later on
October 21st the first season of the
series is expected to have six episodes
whether there'll be a second season is
not yet known however it is possible
that we will see ironheart again in
Young Avengers if you want to know more
about the Young Avengers you can also
watch a video from us in which we
explain everything you need to know
about the members in addition Ryan
coogler is also involved in the series
he already directed The Two Black
Panther movies meaning he already knows
Dominique Thorne very well until we see
a first trailer it will surely take a
while the series is not scheduled to be
released until the fall of 2023 but we
might get a little preview in the
post-credits scenes of the upcoming
Marvel movies
so far nothing is noted with the plot
and even in the comics there are no
connections made between ironheart and
the villains so we will have to get a
little creative at this point we
emphasize once again that nothing about
the plot has been confirmed yet so we're
only presenting our ideas as we know
Riri will go back to MIT to continue her
studies since she had to leave her suit
in wakanda she will surely do everything
she can to build a new one it is
conceivable that she will come into
contact with Ezekiel stain for the first
time while procuring the parts or that
he will take notice of her however now
that she has gained her first experience
in the superhero business she will first
go in search of her father's killer the
latter as we know died in a shootout
where he was actually only with Riri and
her best friend in the park her dad and
her best friend did not survive the hail
of bullets leaving her traumatized it is
quite possible that it turns out her
father's killer is Parker Robbins the
latter is no longer the petty criminal
he once was but has already become the
hood in the meantime As She searches for
him she finds out that he has special
powers so she sets out in full speed to
build a new suit to confront Zeke in
doing so stain might get in her way but
since you can't defeat him on her own
she looks for help she might contact
Pepper Potts for the first time to get
access to some of Tony's material
although Gwyneth Paltrow was not
mentioned in the cast yet it can be
assumed that there'll be the one or
other crossover despite better
technology it will still be tough for
her to stand up for the two villains she
might be helped out in the end by Kate
Bishop AKA Hawkeye after all she's still
after the Kingpin Parker's father worked
for the dangerous underworld boss and so
she might have become aware of Parker as
well but as already mentioned these are
only speculations we will know more at
the latest when the first trailer for
the series will be released until then
we'll just have to wait and see
all right that was our series preview
for ironheart who do you think Riri will
have to face in the new series and will
the Young Avengers finally be introduced
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up see you next
time
[Music]